[Music]
update now to a crash investigation
they've been following pretty closely
surveillance video seems to show just
the seconds leading up
to a deadly wreck involving a unlv
basketball recruit
the i-team's david charns joining us now
from the newsroom with the details that
you'll only see
on 8 news now recruit zayon collins is
facing charges of dui resulting in death
and reckless driving resulting in death
metro police saying collins crashed a
dodge challenger into another car at the
intersection of fort apache and furnace
gulch
now look carefully at this surveillance
video sent to us by a viewer taken at
fort apache in gomer at the time of the
crash
gomer just two streets down there from
furnace gulch
it shows a gray dodge challenger
speeding down that road
and if you follow the car up to the next
intersection that's where furnace gulch
is
you can just see the beginning of that
collision with a white car
as it takes a right also worth noting is
collins past violations when it comes to
driving
a search of traffic case records shows
he was stopped for speeding that's
exceeding the posted speed limit by 21
miles per hour
or greater that happened in september
2018.
he was stopped again in november 2018
for the same violation
and then in july 2020 stopped for
driving the wrong way
on a one-way road reporting from the
newsroom i'm david charns 8 news now